estaba en los 80 es muy como como de
moda el materialismo histórico como
forma de explicar absolutamente todo lo
que rico ocurría en el mundo se suponía
que la sociedad estaba dividida en una
estructura económica y una
superestructura donde estaba la
ideología la cultura del arte y que todo
se definía en las relaciones económicas
y el resto de la construcción social era
un reflejo para sí mecánico y automático
de lo que sucedía en la estructura
económica y que la única forma de
cambiar el mundo era cambiando la
estructura económica y entonces vino
todo el discurso revolucionario todo el
discurso socialista todo el discurso
comunista que durante un tiempo dominó
la agenda de la geopolítica
la cos modernidad el desarrollo
tecnológico un poco fueron demostrando
que esa actuación no era tan exacta y
que de pronto había a nivel de la
cultura de la superestructura y de la
ideología elementos que podían cambiar
el universo que podían cambiar las
relaciones políticas que podían cambiar
incluso las relaciones económicas y se
empezó a hablar entonces de las
narrativas y de la importancia de las
narrativas y esa nueva perspectiva hizo
que es casi que se re leyera la historia
casi que se eligiera la ciencia así que
se reeligiera todo el recorrido que
había hecho al ser humano y muchos
filósofos historiadores fueron
descubriendo o llegando a la conclusión
de que el ser humano el homo sapiens
realmente más que estar bien lo que era
era una especie animal capaz de imaginar
que quizás lo que lo hizo una especie
diferente y lo que le permitió
apropiarse del mundo para bien o para
mal eso ya es otra discusión era su
posibilidad de imaginar las cosas que no
estaban concretas que no eran el entorno
concreto específico de inventar mundos
de inventar realidades de inventar cosas
lo que hoy conocemos como creatividad la
creativa de creatividad expresión es
precisamente eso inventar cosas que no
hay en el contexto y en el entorno
llamado natural o real pero más
importante que inventar mundos e
inventar realidades lo que hacía el ser
humano es que era capaz de vivir en esas
realidades imaginables que era capaz de
construir su comportamiento y sus
relaciones en esas realidades
artificiales e imaginadas inventos
religión es un invento estados inventos
filosofías y todo esto es producto de
una creatividad
entonces hoy en día nos estamos
asistiendo a un momento único en la
historia en que hemos empezado a
reconocer
que somos capaces de inventar la
realidad en la cual quisiéramos vivir y
por eso gana tanta importancia las
narrativas
inicialmente en ese recorrido histórico
las narrativas pertenecían a una pequeña
élite que era quien imaginaba los mundos
en la época de la monarquía los grandes
artistas hacían parte de la corte eran
subvencionados por la corte habían el
mecenazgo y ellos en su en su relación
única con él con él con la obra
inventaba en esos mundos y luego los
imponían casi que no había participación
de los grandes conglomerados en la
definición de la narrativa liberal y del
mundo imaginario en el cual vivir un
poco después de que empieza a surgir la
burguesía después de que se supera el
feudalismo y la edad mediante acción
prima una burguesía de trabajadores con
poder adquisitivo ha sentido algo que va
a ser fundamental en la historia de este
mundo imaginado que son las masas
habidas de entretenimiento y surge el
entretenimiento y con el surgimiento del
entretenimiento que mencionadas por
primera vez en la construcción de las
narrativas se asoma el ciudadano común y
corriente se asoman las grandes mayor
porque el entretenimiento siempre ha
sido un espacio de negociación
entre los artistas y el público y quién
consume esas construcciones en el arte
no hay tal en el arte lo único que se
respeta en la relación de la pista con
su obra en el arte que se asome el
público es una presencia incómoda pero
soledad ebro que picasso nunca estuvo
pensando en público cuando estaba
haciendo sus obras y son tan importantes
en la generación de los imaginarios como
también lo son las construcciones del
entretenimiento esos productos dentro
del mundo donde nos encontramos los
creadores y
los consumidores de esas creaciones y
por eso en el caso del entretenimiento y
de la cultura en general y de la
identidad en particular que nos ocupa es
tan tan tan tan peligroso que se
desbalance ese equilibrio que sanz por
eso me preocupa mucho cuando hacemos
tanto énfasis en conocer a quién le
vamos a hablar
yo creo que no hay nada más perverso en
la historia del entretenimiento que el
algoritmo
porque es que parte del encanto que
tiene la creatividad
es que le plantea a su espectador cosas
que no esperaba preguntarle a la gente
que le gustaría ver me parece que es el
absurdo grande que se puede concebir
porque es que la gente no sabe que le va
a gustar ver en el gustar ver siempre en
el gusto siempre un elemento de sorpresa
cierto en el gusto siempre hay un
elemento inesperado
yo hablo mucho con el jefe y le digo por
qué porque afortunadamente en el caso de
nuestra televisión colombiana tenemos
una televisión que no he hecho mí mismo
pero cuando voy a las ferias tú lo sabes
un reconocimiento de nuestra telebista
afortunadamente esta televisión desde
épocas recordando gómez agudelo ha
tenido un un sector empresarial y
directivo ya abiertos en su mente a las
audaces y siempre le digo acuérdese que
el éxito y el fracaso tiene el mismo
origen una audacia alguien mencionaba
que cuando se acomete un audaz
se está un poco renovando la cultura
cuando estamos atendiendo al algoritmo y
a lo que la gente nos está en lo que
quiere ver estamos estancando la cultura
porque además la identidad de la cultura
son instancias dinámicas no existe una
cultura y una identidad que se quedó
planteada en
esto siempre es algo que cambia que se
modifica y que cambiamos creadores y
consumidores entonces ni hay que
desequilibrar por el lado de los
creadores tampoco nos podemos volver
unos absolutos dictadores que vamos a ir
qué es lo que vamos a poner en la agenda
pero tampoco y me parece peligrosísimo
podemos agachar los frente a las
demandas del público porque nos vamos a
quedar en una media cuando la gente se
le pregunta que les gustaría ver siempre
contestar lo último que les gustó ver
porque cómo va a saber lo que le va a
gustar en el futuro
ahora hablando de identidad
el entretenimiento cómo tiene que tener
esa cercanía con el río porque vive de
la diferencia desde el arte y el arte
subvencionado del arte de corte el
entretenimiento necesita de ese diálogo
con el público y necesita de esa
seducción del público y finalmente o no
finalmente siempre operan juntos se
descubrió que la manera más efectiva de
conectar con ese público era mediante la
emoción
nosotros como como empresas generador de
contenidos para entretenimiento tenemos
un norte y tenemos una misión que es
emocionar ahora la emoción es
absolutamente hija de la identificación
para que exista una un nivel de emoción
tiene que haber un nivel de
identificación
ahí me gusta usar un ejemplo que ilustra
muy bien esto y es el ejemplo de la
fórmula 1 antes de juan pablo montoya
que era la fórmula 1 nosotros una cosa
lejana habíamos de un sumar queralt
[ __ ] porque se las ganaba a todas pero
no había absolutamente ningún compromiso
emocional
y por lo tanto no había audiencia entre
la fórmula aparece montoya y totalmente
cambia el panorama y empezamos a
madrugar los sábados y los domingos
imagínese usted el domingo en guayaba o
solo a las siete de la mañana pendientes
de la carrera porque porque aparece
alguien que se llama montoya apellido
más nacional que montoya no existe
segundo porque siempre quedaba de
segundo y si hay una característica
nacional es que nos muestra el segundo
lugar nosotros nosotros sacamos el carro
de umbrales cuando quedamos de segundos
o de quintos cuando ganamos incluso este
país tienen limpia es parte de su
identidad y una relación con con el
técnico bastante particular cuando
alguien de nosotros gana empezamos a
sospechar de empezar a parecernos un
poco antipático y antes esperamos que
siempre gana nos lo castigamos lo último
no nosotros nos gusta el segundo lugar y
montoya siempre quedaba del segundo
tercero montoya nunca tenía la culpa de
nada
y ese es el país más inocente del mundo
aquí nadie tiene la culpa de nada
y 4o montoya nuevas mentiras manejaba
como colombiano entonces teníamos a
montoya segundo inocente de todo y
manejando como si estuviera en la cárcel
como no íbamos a encontrarnos
identificados en él y ahí aparecía la
emoción y ahí aparece automáticamente la
identificación y de la mano de la
implicación es lo que para nosotros los
que hacemos contenido de entretenimiento
es tan importante
ok pero eso lo proponemos nosotros y lo
ponemos en la agenda y el público no lo
válido no lo había o no lo va
transformando pero cuando vamos a
empezar a pensar de allá para acá vamos
a empezar incluso a afectar sssss en esa
bonita construcción que es una identidad
compartida
pero también hoy en día enfrentamos como
se ha venido hablando acá una amenaza
muy grande que es nuevo panorama
mediático la nueva globalización y la
digitalización
porque fácilmente ese equilibrio y ese
diálogo y ese que se encuentra en el
contenido perfectamente se puede romper
cuando la generación del contenido
d
personas que no pertenecen a nuestra
propia a nuestra propia sociedad a
nuestro propio entorno
entonces yo creo que sí sí estamos
enfrentando un peligro y un peligro que
afectan esos esos elementos de identidad
y de hecho también un poco un poco en el
por por las mismas características
nuestras de tener un medio que apele a
las mayorías porque nosotros no en el
caso de la televisión abierta que es el
medio en el que nos manejamos nosotros
nos podemos permitir en el general el
contenido de dicho nosotros tenemos que
ser generadores de un contenido va a
regular la gente y en ese sentido a
veces nosotros incluso
necesitamos ampliar el concepto de
identidad hacia el de pluralidad hacia
el de inclusión hacia el de tolerancia y
al de aceptación
porque un poco siempre nos estamos
preguntando en nuestro interior a quien
más podemos incluir a quien más podemos
traer y personalmente a mí a veces el
concepto de identidad me resulta un
poquito conflictivo sobre todo en estas
épocas de hoy en día donde estamos como
como así como apelando a ciertos
nacionalismos como que estamos apelando
a ciertos sentimientos
y xenofóbicos donde de una u otra forma
y hay que tener mucho cuidado ese
concepto de identidad fácilmente se
puede extraviar porque identidades que
lo que nos define y lo que nos
diferencia de los demás
y de pronto es momento de pensar menos
en identidad y más en pluralidad
- identidad y más en solidaridad
cierto menos en identidad e imagen
tolerancia
que de pronto pueden ser no solamente
discursos y narrativas en el caso
nuestro nos convoquen desde lo local
sino que de producto pueden llegar a ser
valores un poco más oportunos más
necesarios y más funcionales en el
momento específico que está viviendo
nuestro planeta puesto
entonces un poco la pregunta piensa
será que debemos pensar dejar de pensar
menos sin identidad y más en pluralidad
inclusión tolerancia y solidaria
[Aplausos]